.
AINSLEY: THANK Y SO MUCH,
GRIF
LET'S BNG IN CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN TO RCT TO THIS , GOO
RNING TO YOU, CONGRESSMAN
>> GOOD MORNINGINSLEY.
AILEY: THEY'RE SING BIDENADMINIR
WE'REENDING YOU BACK, THE
BORDERSRE CLOSEDO WHY
ARE WE SEEING HUNDREDSF
THOUSANDS O ILLAL IMMIGNTS
CRSING OVER?
>> BECAUSE THE MESSAGE IS SENT.
YOUNOW,OOK, WN YOU PAY
PEOP NOT TO WORK YOU SHOULDN'T
BE SURPRISED WHEN YOU CAN'T FIND
WOERS WHEN YOU DEFUND POLICEYOUE
U GET MOR CRIME AND WHEN YOU
SEND A MESSAGE FROHE WHITE
HOUSE WE'LL STOP BUILDIN THE
WALL AND GET RID OF THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLY YOU
SHOULDT BE SURPRISED WHEN THEM
COME IO THE COUNTRY,O WE
N'T KNOW WHERE THO HAITIAN
GRANTS ARE AND NOWHERE ARE
,000 MORE COMING?
IS IS THE MS YOU HE WHEN
YOU SEND THERONGESSAGES FM
THE WHITE HOUSE AND YOU
IMEMENT THE WRO POLICS, SO
HE WE G AIN.
WE ACTUALLY HAD ARIEFING LAST
WEEK, AINEY, FROM THE
DICIARY COMMITTEE FM THE
BIDEN ADMISTRATION, AND
THEY ACTUALLY TOLD US, THEY SD
WE THINK, BECSE WE BASICALLY
KED, WHERE ARE THEY?
HOW MANYRE IN AMERICA?WHERE AREY
,OW MANY DID YOU
SENDACK,HEY COULDN'TELL US
THE NUMBERS BUT THE ALSO SAID
THINK A NUMBER O THEM HAVE
WENT BACK.
I MEAN, THE MAKHIS THOUSAND
MILE TRECK A THEY ARE GOING T
TURNARND?
THEYCTUALLY TOLDS THAT SO
THEY HAVE NODEA HOW TO HDLE
THIS A WHEN YOU SEND THE WRONG
MESSAGES FROMHE WHITE HOUSE
BAD THIS HAPPEN.
STEVE: WELL CONGREMAN, THEYDON'D
LIKE TO SEEEOPLE COME INTO THE D
, AND THE OTHER HALF OF
THE COUNY WANTS TO HE THEM
ALL COME O IN.
>> YEAH, THEYUST KEEP
MIEADING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
BUT AGAIN, I THINK IT'S PROBLY
RE THAN 15,000.
SOME OF T NUMBERS THEY TD US
LAST WK IT'0, 30,000N
THIS CARAVANHIS LONG MCH
WARDS OUR SOUTHERNORDER.
IT'SROBABLY A BIGGER NUMR
AN EVENHAT, ANDY GSS IS
E 15,000 THAT WE HRD ABOUTOVERH,
THAT'S PROBABLY A BIGGER NBER
WELL AND WHEN YOU THINK WHEN
THE FOCUSECOMES ONEREA, THE
AR AROUND THE DELIO
BRIDGE, A KINDS O PEOPLE A
GETTG IN, GOING AROUND THA
AREAOO, SO WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT
OSE INDIVIDUAL WHO WERE IN
THE UNTRY, SO THIS IS A TOTALME,
JUST NINE MONTHS AGO, WE HAD A
SECURE BORDER.
THIS KIND OF CHAOS ALL UNFOLDSID
THIS PROBABLY ERY INTERVIEW I
THE LAST MTH.
EVERYONTH GOTORSE, MARCH W
THE LARGEST MONTHN RECORD FOR
ILLEGALROSSINGS, UNT
APRIL, APRIL WASHE LARGESTMONTH0
LEGAL MRANTS ENCNTERS ON
OU BDER, THIS IS A COMPLE
DISASTERUT IT'S A AT THE
FE OF JOE BEN AND HIS
ADNISTRATION.
BRIAN:  FINAL THOUG IS ONE
THING I THINK MARK MORGAN &
COMPY WERE GOOD AT DOING W
GOING TOHESE OTHER COURIES
SAYING LISN, YOU GOT TOTOP,
WH ARE YOUR ISSS WITHHOLNG
BA AID UNTIL YOU CAN GET A
CONTRO OF YR BORDER.
WE'RE FRIENDLYITH PANAMA,
WE'RERIENDLY WITH COLOMBI
THEY'RE COMING THROUGH THE  DARI
AN PAS AND ASTAGGERING CLI OF 3I
AUGU.
THERESED TO BE AERY SMALL
NUER DING THE DAY.
GO UP TO PANAMA AND COLBIA AND
SAY GUYS, CONTROL IT, IENTIV
IZE, AND DO IT.
IF ANYONE IS INTERESD IN
STOPPING THE GENESIS OF THE
PROBLEM, TN GO TO WHERE
E PEOPLE ARE.
>> EAH, IHOUGHT IT WAS
INTESTING LAST WEEK, J BIDEN
SPEAD AT THE UNITED NATIONSAND O
OUR RELATIONSHIPITH OUR ALLIES
, AIF IT WASN'T GOODUNDER PRESI.
IT WAS JUST AGREAT UND
PRESENT TRUMP AND WHILE HE'S
SAYING THAT WE HAVE TS
SITUATION THAYOU JUST
DESCBED WHERE WE DON'T HAVETHES,
THIS KIND OF CPERATION WITH
OUR FRIENDS I CENAL AMECA.
DON'T HAVE THEM, WHICH WE D
HAVE, UNDER THE TRUMP
MINITRATION.
I THOUGHT I WAS, I MEAN NOT TOME
BIDEN'SAKING THAT STAMENT WE
ED TO RESTORE OUR RELATIONSP
TH OUR ALLS AT THAT VERY
MOMENT THE DEMOCRATSN CONGRESS
ARE TAKG OUT THE IN DOME
FENSE SYSTE F OUR BEST
ALLIES THETATE OF ISRAEL, THI
IS HOWAD I I
BRIAN:  AND FRANCE RECALLS THEIR
AMBASSOR.
AT'S HOW BAD IT IS, GOOD LK.
YOU GOTTA T.
THAT'SNE OFHE THINGS.
AINSLEY: LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
$3.5 TRIION RECONCILIAON
PACKAG
DEMOCRAT WANT TO RSE THE
BORROWING LIM, REPLICANS
E FURIOUS ABOUTHAT.
TH SAY IT'S GOING TO
PUBLICANS SAY IT'S GOING TO
KI OUROBS, WAGES,
ELECTRICITY, PCES GO UP ANDLEADN
ICH IS THE NUMBER O CONRN
NOW FOR AMECANS.
CORPORATE TAX COULDO UP T 28%
ANDAISE TAXES FOR WEAHY
FAMILIES,ND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IMMIGRATI, PAY FOR
ILLEGAL IMMIGNTS TO GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
>> IT'S AISASTER AND OFCOURSE,N
JOE BIDEN SAID IT'S NOT GOINGO
CO YOU, I MEAN, THESE ARE THE
--BRIAN: E TWEETED THAT.>> TR,
THE HUNTER BIDEN STORY W
DISINFORMATI, MISINRMATION,
AND OH, A.5 TRILLION
GOVERNMENT SPENDING BL WON'T
COST YOU A PENNY.
MEAN, YOU GOTTA BE KIDDING ME.
THIS IS WHAT THEY TL US A
YOUESCRIBED EVERYING THAT
WAS IN IT.
IS THING IS TERRIE FOR THECOUNT.
LET'S HOPE ITOESN'T PASS.
THIS BE EAT.
THISE FIRST TIME WE CLD
ACTUALLY SLOW THEM DOWN, WELLNOE
DECRATS.
LET'S HOPE THEY CAN'T GET IT
DONE AND D'T DO AMORE DAMAGE
TO THE COURY THAN THE ALREADY
HAVE.
STEVE: LET'S TK A LITTLE BITABOD
ABSOTELY NOT, DEMOCTS, WE
ARE NOTOING TO GO ANG WH
CHUCKCHUMER, WE ARE N GOING
TO RAISE THEEBT CEILING ANDE
WILL NOT SIMULTANEOUSL FUND THE
GOVERENT, BECAUSE IT'S
GOING TO RUN OUT OF MON AT
MIDNIGHTN THURSDAY.
THEY DID, THE REPUBLICA DID
SAY WE WILL D A CLEAN
RESOLUTION,HERE WE FUN
VERNMENT, AND WAY FOR
HURRICANE RELIEF, B WE'RE
T GOINGO GO ALONG WITHHE
DEBT CEILING.
EXPLAIN FOR FOLK, JIM, WHYREPUBW
THE DEBT CEILINGO BE RAISED ON
OURATCH.
>> YEAH, BAUSE IF YOU RSE
THE DEBT CEING YOU'RE ALLOWING
IS $3.5 TRILLN WITH ALL OFTHE BO
FORWARD, IF TY GET THE VOTES
FOR IT SO WE'RE LIKENOWING
AT THE DEBT CEILING IS LOOK,JOE,
CHUCK SCHUM CONTROLS THE
SENATE, NANCY POSI
CONTROLS THE HOU OF
REPRESENTATIVE
ITAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
REPUBLICANS.
IF YOU WANT TO RSE THE DEBT
CEILING A YOU CANCTUALLY GET
THE VOTES T DO ALL THE
CRAZY SPENDG YOU WAN TO
CONTIN TOO,HAT'S ON YOU
GUYS.
DON'T TALK TO REPUBLICANS ABOUT
THAT.
AND WE WILLELP THEM IF IT'S
JU SPENDING AT THE CURRENT
LEVE WE COULD BE HELPFUL IN
THAT.WE'RE NOT GOI TO HP IREASE
SPENDING.
WE'RE NOT GOINGOELP WITH
THIS DEBT CEILING INCASE MAKESAY
, THE AMECAN PEOPLE
KNOW THAT.
THEY KNOW TT.
THAT'S WHY THE DEMRATS ARE
TRYING TO BME THE REPUBLINS
WHO D'T CONTROL A DARN THING
IN THIS TOWN.BRIAN: NE THING ISS
A COUNTRY THE W WE LT
AFANISTAN.
BARRASSED WE LT ALLIES ANDCITIZL
THERE, WE LEFT85 BILLION WOR
OFQUIPMENT SLL THERE AND
BEING RESOLD, EMBARRASSED WE
ASKED THE TIBAN TO WATCH OUR
BACKS AS WE TRIED TO GET O OF
THE AIRPORT.AUSTINMCKENZIE, ANDY
WILL BE ON CAPITOL HL TODAY
AN TOMORROW.
TELL ME WHA YOU NEE TO KNOW.
>> WELL THE RST QUESTION I
K GENERAL MILLE ISOUR NAME
ER BEEN ON A BALLOT?
YOU ER RUN FOR OFFICE, MAKIN
THE DECISIONYOU'RE MAKING A
REPORTED BY BOB WOODWARD D
HIS BOOK?
DR. FAUCI ER RUN FOR OFFICE?
JIM COMEY EVERUN FOR OFFIC
THE IDEA THESEEOPLE WHO NEVER
T THEIRAME ONALLOT ARE
MANG DECISIO F THE
AMERAN PEOPLE THAT ISNOT HOW OUS
THE QUESTN I'D A GENERALMILLEYR
FICE AND MAKEHESE KIND
OF DECISIONSHEN YOU CAN OVE
RULE BASICAL THE PSIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES?
IF THIS IN FACTAPPENS OVERRULEP?
FOR GOODNESS SAK THAT IS S
WRONG,O INCONSISTENT WH OUR
CONSTITUTIAL SYSTEM.
I HE THOSE ARE THE KINDF
QUESTIS THAT HE GETSND THEN,
I WOULD GET INTO 13 SERCE
MEMBERS GAV THEIR LIFE FOR
THEIR COUNTRY, ONE FROM THE
FOUR DISTRICT OF OHIO,
AMERICANS LEFT BIND, ALLIES
LEFT BEHIND $8BILLION OF
EQUIPMT AND WEANSEFT
BEND AND JOE BIDEN, THE
COMMANR-IN-CHIEF, CALLS
THAT AN EXTRAORDARY SUCCESS?ARE?
SO TT'SHE KIND OF TE I'D
TAKE WITH GENERALILLEY.
I'M NOT ONHAT COMMITT BUT
I'M SURE SOME OF MYEPUBLICAN
COLLEAES WILL DOUST THAT.STEVE:R
PEOPLEROMHE PENTAGON A
ON CITOL HILL GO WELL YOU KW
WHAT H WAS DOING WHERE HE
CALLEDIS COUNTERPA, THAT'SNORMA.
I THIN THE AVERA AMERICAN,
JI NEVER RLIZED THAT A TOP
GENERAL BE CAING UP HISOUNT
ER PT IN CHINA SAYING O
YOU THINK YOUROSS IS CRAZY
MINE IS CRAZIER AND I'M NOT
GOING TOET HIM DP THE BOM
ON YOU.>> YEAHND I HE SS TO OUR
ENEM THE CHINE, HISCOUNTERPART F
WE'RE COMIN I'LL GIVE Y A
HEADS UP, I HE SAI THAT, THAT
IS ABSOLUTY WRONG.
TOLANCE WHATSOEVEROR THAT
ND OF STATEME.
DON'T KNO BUT THE OTHER
QUESTIONOU'D WANTO ASK
GENERAL MILLEYS WHAT IN T
WORLDRE YOU DOING TALKING
TO REPTERS ANYWAY?
YOUR NE IS N ON A BOLRD
LOT, YOU DON'T RUN FOR OFFICE.SE
DID I BECAUSE HE WANTED TOHOW
B WOODWARD H WAS THE ADULT IN
THE ROOM.
AINSLEY: CAN W NOT GET THE
TRANRIPTS TO DETERMINE
WHETR OR  NOT HE DID SAY THAT?
>> HOPE SO BUT I DOU IT
PPENS WITH DEMOCTS IN
CONTROL.
IAN:  LT. COLONELTUART SHELL
ER CAME OUT AND SPOKE AND
SAIDHEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO O GERALS AND
COMMANDERS AER THE AFGHANIAN
MARINE FOR 17 YEARS INSTEADF
RETING IN A YEAR, HE QUIT.
D NOW, THEY ARE GNG TO T
HIMND PUT HIM IN JAIL AS HE
WAIT TRIAL.
T ME ASK YOU SOMETHING.GENERAL E
OV FORCES ALONG WITH SECRERY
OF DEFSE AUSTI
JUST KILLED0 CIVILIANSND
SEVEN KID
WE HAD3 SERCE MEN AND WOM
DIE GUARDIN AN AIRPT, THAT
WAS BEING GUARDED BY THE TALIBAI
TRIAL?
WHERE'S TIR TRI?
>> NO, INOW.
YOU CANEEL TT INDIVIDL'SFRUSTRA.
YOU C FEEL THE AMERICANEOPLE
'S FRUSTRATION WIT WHAT
THEY SEE AND WHAT THEY HEAR.
M JUST SO TIRED OF THE DOUE
STANDARD.
THERE'S O SET OF RES FOR THE
LITE IN TS TOWN,
DIFFERENT S OF RULES FOR ALL
US REGULAR AMERICANS A THIS
SEEMS TO FIT INTO THAT
CATEGORY.
I'M SO SIC AND TIRED OF THA
AND AMERICANS ARE SICK AND TIRED
OF THAT AND THE PRESS, YOU GUY
DO A GREATOB BUT THEMAINSTRE PRG
FOR PEOP IN THE BUREARACY
WHO ABIDE BY DIFRENT SET OF
RULES AND STANDARDS THAN ALL OF
US ARICANS, IT DRIVESSLL
CRAZY.
GOD BLE THIS INDIVIDUAL.
GOD BLESSHOSE FAMILIESF
THOSE 13, I MEAN, M SOVIAK IS
AN IIVIDUAL FROM THE 4TH
DISTRICT OF OHIO, HE WAS JT A
GRT YOUNG MANERVING OUR
COUNY, GAVE HIS LE FOR OUR
COUNTRY, A THEN WE SEEHIS
KIND OF STUFF HAPPENING
IT'S FRUSTRANG.
BRIAN:  OUR COMMAERS ARE NOT
WORTHY OF OUR WAR FIGHTS
TH'S THE PROBLEM.AINSLEY: THE MS
JAILED HIS DAD SAI ALL OUR SON
DID IS ASKHE QUESTION TT
EVERODY WAS ASKING THEELVES
BU THEY WE TOO